mes collègues
nous poursuivons aujourd'hui notre cycle
d'audition audition consacrée à l'avenir
des concessions autoroutières après
avoir entendu les auteurs du rapport de
la commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur
le sujet des dirigeants de société
concessionnaires d'autoroute et Bernard
romans ancien président de l'Autorité de
régulation des transports nous recevons
aujourd'hui des représentants des trois
associations d'usagers des autoroutes
aussi je suis ravi d'accueillir monsieur
Rodolphe Lantz secrétaire général de la
Fédération nationale des transports
routiers la FNTR Monsieur Philippe
Nozière président de l'association 40
millions d'automobilistes et Madame
Dominique allaume daube
administratrice de l'Union nationale des
associations familiales du neuf
président du Département habitat et
cadre de vie environnement et
développement durable
à titreliminaire je me permets de
rappeler une intention de notre
commission qui à travers ce cycle
d'audition souhaite anticiper la fin des
contrats de concessions autoroutier et
dresser le bilan des concessions telles
qu'elles ont été pensées et mises en
oeuvre jusqu'à présent je rappelle
simplement que la part modale du
transport routier reste dans notre pays
très majoritaire puisqu'elle s'établit à
84% pour le transport intérieur de
voyageurs et à 87% pour le transport
intérieur de marchandises dans ce
contexte les autoroutes jouent un rôle
structurant pour la mobilité de nos
concitoyens mais aussi pour le fret
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons
naturellement recevoir des représentants
des usagers des autoroutes pour
déterminer dans quelle mesure les
concessions actuelles répondent ou non à
leurs besoins et mieux intégrer leur
préoccupations à l'avenir avant toute
chose et de matière générale je
souhaitais entendre votre point de vue
sur les contrats de concession
autoroutier tels qui sont mises en œuvre
aujourd'hui et avoir votre regard sur
les relations entre les sociétés de
concessionnaires d'autoroutes et l'État
je souhaiterais également vous
interroger sur la question centrale des
pairages autoroutiers certaines sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute récemment
annoncé de nouvelles augmentations
notamment quand tenu du fait de
l'indexation de leur augmentation à 70 %
sur l'inflation comment avez-vous
accueilli ces annonces vous semble-t-il
acceptable ou du moins absorbables pour
les personnes ou les entreprises que
vous représentez dans quelle mesure les
réductions prévues pour les trajets
réguliers sont-elles efficaces selon
vous s'agissant en particulier des
professionnels du transport routier
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît indiquez
quelle est la proportion de dépenses
liées au pH sur l'ensemble des dépenses
totales
pourriez-vous également nous livrer
votre opinion en tant qu'usager sur la
qualité du réseau autoroutier concédé
plusieurs auditions ont mis en lumière
l'excellente qualité du réseau
autoroutier français partagez-vous ce
constat du point de vue des
infrastructures de recharge quel est
votre avis sur le déploiement du réseau
de bornes à ce jour quelles sont vos
attentes en la matière pour l'avenir
dernière question plus prospective je
vous laisserai ensuite la parole dans
l'ordre que vous souhaitez celle de
l'avenir des contrats autoroutiers
qu'elle devrait selon vous en êtes les
priorités je vous laisse le soin de
prendre la parole qui veut commencer
et bien allez-y
monsieur le Président nous vous
remercions vivement de nous avoir invité
à nous exprimer lors de cette table
ronde consacrée aux usagers des
autoroutes et ainsi de ne pas avoir
oublié les usagers professionnels la
Fédération nationale des transports
routiers et l'organisation
professionnelle leader du secteur du
transport routier et de la logistique
elle représente des entreprises de
toutes tailles des groupes des ETI des
PME et des TPE les FNTR rassemble 48%
des entreprises adhérentes à une
organisation professionnelle de la
convention collective transport routier
et activités auxiliaires soit 5300
entreprises qui emploient 242 000
salariés
la trentaine de syndicats de la fenthe
l'ensemble du territoire national et la
SNCF dispose depuis plus de 25 ans d'un
bureau permanent à Bruxelles
lors de notre dernière audition sur le
sujet au Sénat le 16 juillet 2020 dans
le cadre de la commission d'enquête sur
les concessions autoroutières nous
avions pu rappeler qu'il existe un lien
direct entre la privatisation des
sociétés d'autoroutes et les multiples
tentatives depuis de taxer les camions
dont faisaient partie les codes en effet
la fit créée en 2004 avait vocation à
être financé par les dividendes des
sociétés d'autoroute perçues par l'État
mais son financement était brutalement
asséchés en 2006 par la privatisation
des sociétés d'autoroutes
les camions représentent en 2021
16,2% du trafic mais 35% des 10,3
milliards d'euros de recettes des péages
la recette unitaire kilométrique moyenne
sur les réseaux concédés s'élève à 23,9
centimes d'euros au kilomètre en
évolution cumulée depuis 2007 cette
recette kilométrique augmente de plus
37,4%. soit un taux de croissance
moyenne annuel de plus 2,3% entre 2007
et 2021
rapporté au kilométrage total des
camions le coût des péages a été
multiplié par 2,4 depuis 2000 soit un
taux de croissance moyenne annuel de
plus 4,1%
sur le long terme les entreprises du TRM
sont donc confrontées à une hausse
marquée du coup des péages
nous payons bien au-delà de notre
utilisation du réseau concédé dans le
cadre les assises de la mobilité le
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures a remis un rapport
l’année 7 de ce rapport fait état des
rapports du Conseil Général de
l'environnement et du développement
durable jamais publié qui en prenant en
compte les externalités considèrent que
les poids lourds diesels assument
jusqu'à 225% du taux de couverture sur
autoroute et 130% sur l'ensemble du
réseau concédé et non concédés nous
payons donc beaucoup sur les autoroutes
mais cet argent ne va pas à l'état qui
ne peut donc pas en disposer pour le
réseau non concédé et notamment son
entretien
nous sommes des clients des sociétés
d'autoroute et quand contrairement à ce
qui est dit et tout cela relève de la
directive européenne le péage n'est
autre que la contrepartie de l'usage de
l'infrastructure il n'est pas la
contrepartie d'un service
la preuve lors de la crise sanitaire est
plus précisément du confinement de 2020
nous n'avons pas obtenu la gratuité des
péages alors que le service a été
quasiment inexistant tout au moins dans
les premières semaines de ce premier
confinement
en 2022
45,1% des kilomètres effectués par les
camions l'ont été sur autoroute soit en
moyenne
48906 km par véhicule
par véhicule les dépenses annuelles de
péage s'élèvent en 2022 à 10429 euros
soit
0,086 euros par kilomètre soit 15% des
coûts kilométriques directs qui
comprennent le carburant les
pneumatiques l'entretien réparation les
péages et 6,16% du prix de revient moyen
annuel d'un véhicule
de 2012 à 2022 le coût des péages au
kilomètre parcouru à progresser de plus
24,68%. soit un taux de croissance
annuel moyen de plus 2,2%. cette dérive
témoigne de l'inflation annuelle
régulière des tarifs autoroutiers et
encore ces chiffres ne prennent pas en
compte la revalorisation tarifaire au
1er février 2023 qui en ajoutant Société
Historique les sociétés ATM ATM B et SFR
ressort à plus de 5% pour les catégories
3 et 4
certes une utilisation plus systématique
de l’autoroute procure des économies de
coût marginaux de carburant de
pneumatiques et de maintenance en raison
d'une vitesse plus régulière cependant
l'arbitrage entre économie et surcoût de
se faire au cas par cas la rentabilité
d'un recours à l'autoroute n'est jamais
garantie la décision est prise en
fonction des conditions et des
contraintes précises de chaque transport
la distance
délai de livraisons la gestion des
plannings conducteurs etc mais il
convient de remarquer que de nombreux
interdictions de circuler tendent à
orienter une plus grande partie du
trafic vers le réseau concédé
pour résumer
les péages pèsent lourdement sur les
entreprises de transport routier de
marchandises dont les marges sont très
faibles 15% des coûts kilométriques
directs 6,6% du prix de revient moyen
annuel d'un véhicule
les coûts des péages progressent trop
fortement par rapport au prix du
transport depuis 2007 la recette
kilométrique unitaire augmente de plus
37,4% et les arbitrages des
transporteurs peuvent se modifier en
fonction du coût des péages en faisant
l'arbitrage entre les économies et le
surcoût et on le rappelle la rentabilité
d'un recours à l'autoroute n'est pas du
tout garanti
merci
ça fonctionne oui alors je représente
Luna l'Union nationale des associations
familiales je rappelle que Luna est une
institution qui défend les familles qui
défend les intérêts matériaux des
familles auprès des pouvoirs publics
ceci dit nous ne sommes pas des
spécialistes des professionnels comme
vous monsieur et nous n'avons pas les
mêmes sources de renseignements et donc
je vais vous exposer ce que l'une à
France sur ce sujet donc en sachant que
nous ne sommes pas des professionnels de
ce sujet donc nous avons bien regardé
l'inflation et les péages et les tarifs
des péages des principaux axes du réseau
français augmenté en moyenne de 4,75% à
partir du préfet février dernier selon
le ministère des Transports en 2022 ils
avaient déjà augmenté de 2% il s'agit
d'une moyenne certains tronçons peuvent
avoir des hausses supérieures
comme on sait chaque année les prix des
péages sont réévalués au 1er février
après discussion entre l'État et les
principales sociétés qui exploitent les
autoroutes de l'Hexagone ainsi
l'augmentation des tarifs des pH sur
l'autoroute est appliquée à partir du
1er février 23 sur les autoroutes VINCI
Autoroutes Paris Rhin Rhône autoroute
Rhône-Alpes etc
alors comme a dit Monsieur le péage est
calculé en partie le prix des péages est
calculé en partie sur le taux
d'inflation à hauteur de 70% selon
une théorie de calcul qui qui a été
déterminé avec les pouvoirs publics ce
70% du taux d'inflation au 31 octobre de
l'année précédente plus le coût des
travaux non prévu et demandés par l'État
ainsi que le rattrapage du gel des
péages annoncé par ses collègues royales
à leur Miss de l'environnement en 2015
et qui s'étale sur plusieurs années
alors on nous avons obtenu des
ristournes pour les gros rouleurs et des
certaines réductions l'État avait
demandé aux opérateurs un coup de pouce
en faveur du pouvoir d'achat la hausse
de 2022 et la conclusion de négociation
serrée l'ancien juillet entre le
gouvernement et les compagnies
autoritaires autoroutière et finalement
elle est un petit peu inférieure à
l'inflation
cette ristourne pour les gros rouleurs
qui avaient été une demande de Luna
d'ailleurs en partie et est accordée au
gros rouleur qui effectue plus de 10
allers-retours par mois sur le même
itinéraire sur certains réseaux Vinci
APRR et sa nef cette réduction a été un
petit peu augmentée puisqu'elle n'était
que 30% auparavant
les automobilistes réguliers disposant
d'un badge télépéage et empruntant les
autoroutes Vinci APRR et SANEF pour le
même trajet au moins 10 fois par mois
bénéficie d'augmentation de cette
histoire le ministre des Transports a
souhaité limiter les hausses de prix
pour la vie quotidienne en protégeant
ceux qui doivent utiliser la voiture
pour aller travailler et en encourageant
la transition écologique ce point était
une demande importante de l'UNAF qui a
aussi souligné l'intérêt écologique de
réduire les péages pour les véhicules
comme ceux en autopartage en auto en
covoiturage et les véhicules familiaux
occupés à noter les sociétés
d'autoroutes avaient annoncé la mise en
place de voies distinctes sur certains
tronçons d'autoroutes pour faciliter le
transport des gens en covoiturage mais
ceci n'est pas encore très visible ni
réalisé on se pose la question
pourrait-on compter dessus rapidement ou
bien prévoir un boîtier particulier au
péage inclus dans une classe
nouvelle adaptée à l'autopartage au
covoiturage avec un contrôle par exemple
il y a des caméras partout c'est
peut-être facile à faire les Luna avait
demandé une véritable équité pour les
déplacements contraints et approuvent
donc les efforts qui ont été faits dans
ce sens alors la réduction pour les
véhicules électriques
alors réduction de l'augmentation
réduction même annulation de
l'augmentation pour les véhicules
électriques
les propriétaires de voitures
électriques ont une réduction de 5% sur
leur tarif pendant toute l'année 2023
sur certains réseaux ce qui revient à
une annulation de cette hausse du prix
des péages pour ce type de véhicules
j'ai pas mis dans mon dans mon rapport
j'ai voulu qu'hier après-midi que la
France était à 100.000 bornes là
électrique ces jours-ci dont 7000 sur
les autoroutes
donc c'est ça nous paraît important
il manque encore selon Luna la formation
sur le nombre et les lieux
d'implantation de bornes par
concessionnaire
donc on voudrait savoir où pouvoir
recharger sa voiture quand on se déplace
sur un long trajet il est prévu pour
2023 pour fin 2023 de nombreux
équipements nouveaux de bornes
électriques toutefois ce sont des
projets pour l'ensemble quels sont les
projets pour l'ensemble du réseau
l'usager en tout état de cause est en
mesure d'exiger une bonne répartition
territoriale de leur lieu d'implantation
car il a besoin d'être informé et
rassurer quand il prend la route savoir
où il va pouvoir recharger pour sa
voiture pour surtout pour les longs
trajets ou pour les vacances les moyens
d'accès à ces bornes doivent être bien
balisés sur les airs et accès
d'autoroute
en ce qui concerne le surcoût des péages
le cabinet d'études Aster calcule que la
haute de 4,75% pour entraîner un surcoût
moyen de 6,4 € par ménage et par an bon
ça c'est une moyenne sur l'ensemble des
ménages français il y en a 25 millions
il y a des gens qui prennent pas du tout
l'autoroute je pense que quand ça se
concentre sur certains sur ceux qui le
prennent ça fait un surcoût beaucoup
plus élevé et les Français aurait
dépensé en moyenne 135 euros pour les
péages autoroutiers sur l'année 2022
une division par deux de la marge des
sociétés d'autoroutes générer un gain de
pouvoir d'achat de 14 euros par an et
par ménage précise l'étude évidemment ça
paraît pas très très conséquent mais
peut-être pour que ceux qui prennent
régulièrement l'autoroute ce serait
beaucoup plus significatif et enfin nous
avons fait un calcul de du prix au
kilomètre du péage autoroutier selon les
sections d'autoroute
si on recherche les données en matière
de tarif sur le site des associations
françaises de société d'autoroute la SPA
selon les cinq classes de véhicule c'est
on peut on peut la trouver c'est assez
difficile mais on le trouve quand même
le site stipule que sans péage une
augmentation des impôts de 450 euros par
an et par foyer serait inéluctable et on
donne les explications les travaux les
aménagements la muralisation les
services et aussi les informations
utiles sur les prix de dépannage et les
équipements et services pour les
personnes handicapées et PMR on pourrait
aussi saturerger sur les variations de
prix au péage alors nous avons analysé
certains péages
combien une Paris 4,6 centimes du
kilomètre Le Mans Paris 9,8 Paris Lyon
8,4 bon j'en passe quelqu'un Dourdan
Paris je me souviens qu'il y avait des
gens Dourdan la dernière
la réunion de du 16 juillet 2020 ces 3
centimes Paris Rouen c'est 12 centimes
virgule 9 c'est quand même beaucoup plus
et alors le un des plus élevés c'est en
girouan
15,5 euros
15,5 centimes du kilomètre excusez-moi
c'est tout en centime tout ce que j'ai
dit étant centime cela s'explique selon
la soie par la somme de tarifs appliqué
par plusieurs sociétés qui s'ajoutent
quand on fait en Gérois on change de
société d'autoroute
pour l'espace et hausse résulte aussi de
la répercussions de 70% de l'inflation
lequel et qui sont
répercussions qui a été validée par
l'État selon lequel il reste l'État
reste le premier bénéficiaire sur un
ticket de 10 euros 4 euros 20 sont
reversés à l'État au total plus d'une
quinzaine de tronçons ont vu leur prix
bondir depuis 15% depuis 2011
les bénéfices sont pressés par
l'autorisation l'Autorité de régulation
des transports qui indique que la
réduction des coûts d'exploitation avec
l'automatisation des péages et
l'allongement des concessions a servi à
grossir les marges des sociétés ainsi
que par l'Autorité de la concurrence qui
en 2014 avait proposé une nouvelle
formule de calcul des tarifs avec la
prise en compte de l'évolution du tarif
susceptible de l'unité leur hausse voire
de permettre leur baisse
est-ce qu'il faut allonger la durée des
concessions la question est soulevée par
la poursuite sur la poursuite des
concessions autoroutières l'entourage du
ministre de des finances Monsieur le
Maire a étudié à préciser qu'il étudiait
les solutions pour raccourcir la durée
des concessions d'autoroute au vu des
chiffres des produits réalisés et comme
disait monsieur un rapport non publié de
l'Inspection générale des finances de
février 2021 est évocateur de ce sujet
pour Luna il serait nécessaire d'assurer
la transparence au niveau des recettes
pour apporter une confiance accrue de
l'usager au niveau de chaque société
voilà notre notre
participation notre apport monsieur le
Président merci je vais
monsieur le Président merci de nous
recevoir
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes est une association
d'intérêt général
la seule d'ailleurs je crois à être
d'intérêt général l'association de
défense des automobilistes depuis 2014
l'association plaid pour la baisse des
tarifs de péages autoroutiers et elle
avait notamment à l'époque lancé une
pétition intitulée stop au péage trop
cher
et par ailleurs l'association est membre
du comité des usagers
alors à rendre ce que nous souhaitons
nous c'est rendre les autoroutes de
nouveau accessibles à tous
à l'échéance des contrats de concessions
en cours plusieurs options se
présenteront à l'état français
propriétaire des autoroutes pour
organiser leur exploitation et leur
gestion les laboration de nouveaux
contrats de concessions qu'il convient
comme chacun en est bien conscient de
préparer avec soin afin de ne pas
répéter les erreurs qui ont pu être
commises dans les années 90-2000 qui ont
eu pour principale conséquences une
perte de pouvoir d'achat pour les
automobilistes en raison de
l'augmentation constante et importante
des tarifs des péages permise par les
termes des contrats et laissés à la
libre appréciation des sociétés
concessionnaires comme Monsieur la
précisé tout à l'heure effectivement et
Madame également les 70% du taux de
l'inflation c'est quand même
relativement énorme
et une prévoir également une
rationalisation des tronçons routiers
dans les deux cas une solution une
renatualisation pardon des tronçons
autoroutiers dans les deux cas une
solution devra être trouvée et mise en
oeuvre pour réduire de pour l'usager le
coût d'utilisation des autoroutes et que
le service assuré par les sociétés
concessionnaires privées bénéficient au
plus grand nombre
les tarifs sont dissuasifs car avec
l'augmentation des prix de péage
d'autoroute beaucoup d'usagers se
trouvent aujourd'hui
contraint ou choisissent pour faire des
économies des économies de cette dépense
de ne plus emprunter les réseaux
autoroutiers qui est pourtant le réseau
routier le plus sûr de France le risque
d'avoir un accident et
six,6 fois plus important sur les
nationales et 5,25 fois plus important
sur les départementales
l'évolution de la hausse des prix des
péages d'autoroute au nom de
l'investissement dans les
infrastructures de sécurité et les
services se fait donc par hasdoxe
allemand au détriment de l'accessibilité
du réseau et participe au renforcement
des inégalités sociales les jeunes
conducteurs qui constituent aussi le
plus fort risque d'accidents
de mortalité routière les classes
sociales les plus modestes et les
retraités sont ceux qui ont le plus
tendance à renoncer à l'usage de
l'autoroute
du point de vue de notre association 40
millions d'automobilistes la décision de
poursuivre par le biais des contrats ou
remettre les autoroutes dans le Gironde
l'État est une problématique politique
qui ne nous appartient pas d'influencer
mais la question du pouvoir d'achat donc
indirectement comme on l'a vu celle de
la sécurité routière et primordial
particulièrement dans ce contexte
économique d'inflation généralisée
aussi l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes émet une proposition
visant à réduire les coûts des péages
autoroutiers pour les usagers au moment
où il les utilise le plus en cohérence
avec une recommandation formulée par
l'Autorité de régulation de transport
dans son dernier rapport de janvier 2023
économie des concessions autoroutières
la modulation des tarifs de péage en
fonction de la congestion doit être
encouragé car elle permet à tenir compte
des variations de la valeur du service
rendu par les autoroutes selon les
périodes phrases qui qui était dans dans
ce dernier rapport donc de l'Autorité de
régulation de régulation des transports
cependant la recommandation de la RT
implique l'élaboration d'une nouvelle
formule de calcul de prix appliquée par
les concessionnaires en fonction du taux
de congestion des tronçons cette mesure
serait à notre avis trop compliquée à
appréhender et pas lisible pour les
usagers c'est pourquoi nous proposerions
plus simplement de faire bénéficier les
usagers d'une réduction
à définir sur le montant de la facture à
acquitter au péage pour les week-ends
les plus fréquentés à titre d'exemple le
concessionnaire SANEF
SAPN a mis en place une expérience de
variations des tarifs en fonction de
l'horaire sur l'autoroute A1 et pour les
Parisiens que vous connaissez bien sur
l'autoroute A14
donc
ce tarifs sont moduler en fonction des
horaires et en fonction des des jours où
nous les automobilistes prennent ces
portions d'autoroute
cette disposition permettrait à la fois
un gain économique important pour ceux
qui font l'effort de décaler l'heure de
leur trajet et de réduire l'engorgement
du trafic et donc également les
émissions polluantes en lissant la
fréquentation des des tronçons sur les
autoroutes au moment des plus grands
départs
cependant
contrairement à sa nef le 40 millions
d'automobilistes
et favorable pour une réduction mais ne
pas compenser cette réduction par une
augmentation sur les autres plages
horaires ce qui est le cas de notamment
l'autoroute à 14
le péage de le péage du tunnel
voilà
merci avant de donner un parole à mes
collègues je voudrais
silence que vous puissiez me répondre
sur une de mes questions qui a été celle
de là de votre avis sur la qualité ou
non du réseau routier du réseau
autoroutier pardon concédé et l'avenir
du contrat de concession autoroutier
comme vous voyez l'avenir
ce président sur l'avenir du des
contrats de concession
je rejoindrai
ce qui vient d'être dit c'est une
décision politique comme l'a été la
décision politique de nationalité de
privatiser les sociétés d'autoroute nous
appartient pas de nous prononcer sur sur
ce point et les discussions
sont en cours et les rapports
s'accumulent sur la qualité sur la
qualité du réseau oui bien sûr d'une
manière générale le réseau autoroutier
et de qualité et heureusement au regard
des tarifs pratiqués et de l'impact de
l'impact de ces ecpage sur les comptes
d'exploitation des sociétés de transport
routiers de marchandises
je voudrais rappeler parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de services le pH c'est l'usage
de l'infrastructure les services c'est
autre chose
d'accord c'est autre chose donc nous en
ce qui concerne la qualité de
l'infrastructure oui bien sûr c'est une
des infrastructures de qualité du
manière générale mais que l'on paye au
prix fort
merci je vais
merci monsieur le Président le prix des
péages à Bondy de 4,75% en cette année
2023 ce qui vient alimenter la rente
dont bénéficie les sociétés
autoroutières pour les usagers sur la
pèse lourd sur le portefeuille avec un
record pour la 28
madame la représentante des familles il
a fait allusion puisqu'il faut
maintenant payer et je pense notamment
au record pour la 28 puisqu'il faut
maintenant payer plus de 30 euros entre
Alençon et Rouen pour seulement 163 km
c'est hausse viennent gonfler des
bénéfices qui sont déjà records 3,9
milliards d'euros en 2021 pour les 25
sociétés autoroutières concessionnaires
selon la RT
le manque à gagner lors des confinements
du covid ayant d'ailleurs été largement
effacé puisque les résultats 2021 ont
été de 11 super 11% supérieur à ceux de
2019 la question des contrats passés
avec l'État lors des privatisations et
donc bien sûr nécessairement étudier et
j'allais dire nécessairement scruter
nous le savons la rente autoroutière est
répartie entre les sociétés
autoroutières et l'État pourquoi pas
tant que le partage reste équilibré or
les sociétés autoroutières ont dégagé
une rentabilité de 12% selon un rapport
de l'Inspection des finances un niveau
bien supérieur au 7,8% attendu lors de
la signature des contrats les principaux
groupes de concessions autoroutières ce
sont défendus de toute sur rentabilité
ou de tout sur profit devant notre
commission lorsqu'ils sont venus nous
voir et ont invoqué la réalisation de
travaux demandés par l'État et financer
par les automobilistes et non pas par
les contribuables alors ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Nozière selon vous
monsieur nozier en votre qualité de
président de l'association
40 millions d'automobilistes quelle
stratégie doit être mise en place pour
s'assurer d'une répartition juste des
profits tout en favorisant le bon
maintien de notre réseau autoroutier
avez-vous déjà fait des propositions
extrêmement concrètes concrètes pardon
au gouvernement en ce sens
merci de votre question
nous nous avons fait depuis
effectivement un certain nombre d'années
de nombreuses propositions au
gouvernement et notamment ce que je ce
que j'ai précisé tout à l'heure c'est
une modulation des tarifs de manière à
ce que cela ne pèse pas trop sur le
budget des des ménages prenant
l'autoroute
je en ce qui concerne je reviendrai sur
sur
ce que disait monsieur Lens tout à
l'heure
nous pouvons en revanche nous nous louer
d'avoir un réseau autoroutier d'une
excellente qualité quand on a un peu
l'occasion d'aller dans d'autres pays
européens
et notamment dans un pays qui est qui
est toujours montré en exemple à savoir
l'Allemagne et bien on s'aperçoit que on
a quand même un réseau qui est très
supérieur au réseau allemand
après
je dirais faire
faire des propositions au gouvernement
pour pour je dirais réduire les tarifs
des péages par le biais d'une
je dirais d'une
d'une intervention auprès des sociétés
des sociétés concessionnaires je pense
que c'est pas non plus
c'est pas non plus tellement notre notre
but je vais venir je veux dire les
sociétés concessionnaires sont à mon
avis
assez grande pour savoir elle-même ce
qu'elle doit faire
merci j'ai la parole à Madame Fréville
merci monsieur le Président merci à nous
intervenants pour leurs éclairages alors
je voulais d'abord interroger
lunaf alors au sujet de l'inflation qui
est suite à la hausse notamment des
4,75% en février 2023 sur les autoroutes
a été évoqué l'évolution du recours à
l'autoroute qui est qui serait en baisse
est-ce que vous avez des chiffres à ce
propos là est-ce que puisque a été
évoqué le fait que bien évidemment se
déplaçait sur l'autoroute c'est être en
meilleure sécurité et avoir nettement
moins d'accidents ne voudrait-il pas
avoir des demandes par rapport au départ
en vacances ou les voitures sont je vais
le dire comme ça plein avec les familles
justement et qu'effectivement s'il y a
un accident c'est beaucoup plus grave
que s'il n'y a qu'une personne bien sûr
dans un véhicule et que donc on devrait
peut-être porter l'accent sur des
demandes par rapport
alors je sais pas des réductions ou je
ne sais pas par rapport au départ en
vacances puisque ce s'il y a été évoqué
que il y aurait moins recours à
l'autoroute on peut donc s'inquiéter du
fait que peut-être qu'on aurait beaucoup
plus de personnes accidentées et après
une autre question alors peut-être sur à
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes que pensez-vous du coup
est-ce que parce que vous n'avez pas
évoqué des recharges bornes électriques
sur les autoroutes là où le consommateur
est captif et où je crois avoir entendu
que les recharges seraient plus
onéreuses que qu'ailleurs sur le réseau
routier donc voilà mes deux questions
merci
alors c'est vrai que on a demandé à
plusieurs reprises madame vous l'avez
sans doute entendu que que des tarifs
particuliers pour les pour les véhicules
familiaux mais véhicules familiaux plein
c'est clair pour nous c'est pas
seulement le papa ou la maman seule dans
sa grosse voiture ça c'est pas mais par
contre avoir on a demandé donc des
réductions régulières pour ces voitures
quand elles sont remplies et donc elles
sont remplies souvent les week-ends en
vacances donc c'est implicite mais ça
vaut peut-être mieux de le dire
clairement parce que c'est vrai et
Monsieur de 40 millions de de
automobilistes l'a bien précisé et je
l'avais pas redit mais on l'avait dit au
mois de juillet 2020 c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup moins c'est une ce sont
des routes moins
sujette à l'accidentologie donc qui sont
plus sur pour les familles c'est clair
et qui sont aussi plus rapide
je sais pas si moi j'ai une famille
nombreuse quand on a quatre enfants qui
crient maman quand arrivons-nous
derrière ben bon si on peut mettre une
heure de moins c'est quand même
appréciable bon je vous fais pas de
dessin donc ça serait important et on
disait nous peut-être avoir un boîtier
au télépéage particulier que ce soit une
classe une nouvelle classe pour ces
voitures familiales
et
j'ai habité longtemps Compiègne donc
avec sur la 1 c'est évidemment ce péage
qui est moduler un peu comme les billets
de train ou les les billets d'avion
selon l'horaire et c'était ça ça
permettait de lisser vraiment la
c'était le week-end seulement je l'ai vu
que le week-end ça permettait de lisser
les embouteillages donc la sécurité et
aussi quand on lisse les embouteillages
on fait moins de moins de d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ça c'est évident
je ne sais pas si j'ai bien répondu à
votre question madame
allez-y alors en ce qui concerne les
bornes de recharge une bande de recharge
électrique sur les autoroutes alors
effectivement il y a d'abord il y en a
très peu
comme l'expliquait madame tout à l'heure
7000 sur les 100000 qui ont été mis en
place sur tout le territoire
mais d'une façon générale on peut dire
que les bornes de recharge électrique
autoroute notamment et les autres
d'ailleurs même qui ne sont pas sur les
autoroutes les bandes de recharge rapide
sont effectivement horriblement cher
on je vais pas dire que aujourd'hui on
paye pratiquement plus cher en faisant
des recharges électriques rapides que du
carburant mais on en est pas très loin
et il faut il faut quand même se
projeter un petit peu dans l'avenir
à savoir que si demain nous avons un
parc automobile
électrique extrêmement étendu
il va y avoir et ça c'est une évidence
un manque à gagner pour l'Etat qui
risquent être extrêmement important à
partir du moment où il y aura moins de
de consommation de de carburant fossiles
et dans ce cas là on peut craindre que
le
coût de recharge augmente de façon
importante
merci je vais
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
merci pour vos interventions je
souhaiterais en fait vous interpeller de
manière peut-être plus volontariste sur
votre vision en fait de l'autoroute de
demain nous sommes à un moment qui est
particulier puisque
il est important que les uns et les
autres nous nous préparions donc à la
sortie
des concessions actuelles soit d'une
remise en concurrence ou sur d'autres
propositions je pense que Monsieur
Jacquin il reviendra sans doute mais du
coup votre vision commune de l'autoroute
de demain est particulièrement
intéressantes pour voir comment les
cahiers des charges pourraient
aujourd'hui évoluer si jamais il y a une
nouvelle mise en concurrence où si
jamais il y a d'autres solutions comment
on pourrait s'inscrire dans une
trajectoire dans une trame d'histoire
d'avenir on voit bien qu'autour des
tarifs aujourd'hui il y a une question
de fond sur la façon dont on devrait
adapter les tarifs en fonction de notre
niveau d'activité
il y a également une question de fond
aujourd'hui sur les accès aux métropoles
avec les autoroutes qui débouchent
souvent sur des rocades et des grandes
difficultés aujourd'hui donc Madame au
niveau de lunaf vous mettiez en avant le
covoiturage des voix qui sont dédiées
tout ça doit s'inscrire d'une manière
beaucoup plus forte dans dans la vision
qu'on doit avoir des autoroutes de
demain est-ce que vous êtes favorable
pour qu'il y ait des forfaits mobilité
durables qui prennent en considération
si aujourd'hui des approches plus
durables aussi en termes de mobilité au
niveau
des autoroutes et sur l'accès notamment
au niveau des métropoles est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à des tarifs différenciés
en fonction des niveaux de vie et par
rapport à au niveau effectivement
d'activités sur le plan du développement
des bornes électriques aujourd'hui il y
a une grande difficulté qui qui est
posée sur on va dire la compatibilité
des moyens de paiement donc c'est une
question aujourd'hui de fond qui crée
quand même beaucoup de difficultés
d'accès quel est votre vision également
sur sur ces sujets là bref comment les
uns et les autres vous pouvez vous
inscrire dans une nouvelle trajectoire
les autoroutes de demain pour nous
permettre nous de prendre en
considération un certain nombre de
propositions
d'orientation
on peut aujourd'hui avec les autorités
organisatrices améliorées bien sûr la
mobilité des services de car de
covoiturage regardez comment les
autoroutes peuvent nous permettre de
définir de nouvelles trajectoires de
mobilité quelles sont vos remarques donc
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
oui je vous en prie même alors c'est
vrai je l'ai dit tout à l'heure on avait
fait cette proposition dès 2020 d'avoir
des des voix dédiées à la fois on voit
entre Roissy et Paris il y a des voies
dédiées ou que prennent les autobus et
les taxis on devrait pouvoir imaginer
parce que finalement le covoiturage
c'est le transport en commun individuel
si on veut donc on pourrait imaginer la
même chose et je pense que ça devrait il
devait avoir ces gens-là avoir un
boîtier particulier une autre une autre
catégorie pour les distinguer et qu'on
est des tarifs particuliers ça c'est sûr
alors l'autoroute de demain révèle
l'autoroute de demain
c'est pas évident je veux dire ça une
seconde
on avait demandé alors c'était
la route l'aspect de la route du lissage
etc il y a aucun souci comme disait
monsieur Landes il y a tout les
autoroutes sont très bon état
ceci dit quand il pleut beaucoup il y a
quand même des revêtements qui sont plus
ou moins agréables et des revêtements
qui absorbent l'eau quand on est sous
une plus battante je pense que ça ça
ajoute à la sécurité de de la route et
puis aussi
nous on voit aussi tous les tout ce
qu'il y a autour de la route en
elle-même c'est tous les services de
restauration
d'hébergement de de repos pour alors moi
je quand c'est une famille qui se
déplace alors en général elle prévoit
faire son trajet quelquefois en deux
jours mais c'est rare c'est souvent en
une journée mais je pense que pour les
pour les gens qui sont en transport
routier c'est certainement différents il
faut qu'ils puissent se coucher
se laver etc donc il y a certainement
tout ça ajouté autour si c'est pas
suffisant et sur les les bords je sais
pas si vous n'avez pas passer de
questions sur les bornes électriques les
bandes de recharge rapide bon j'ai des
souvenirs assez vagues maintenant de
physique mais quand même quand on
recharge rapidement il faut une très
grande puissance
donc voilà P = lui enfin bon bref c'est
des meilleurs donc
il y a quand même ce problème de fournir
c'est pour ça je pense que c'est que
c'est beaucoup plus cher parce qu'il y a
cette puissance à fournir et on voit
aussi que dans un autre ordre d'idée le
carburant est plus cher sur l'autoroute
le carburant classique et plus cher sur
l'autoroute que sur la route ou au
supermarché donc ça paraît logique enfin
ça paraît logique c'est comme ça et s'il
y a une grosse demande on voit par
exemple des des stations Tesla enfin
j'en ai vu plusieurs avec 10 ou 12
bornes de recharge
et bien on peut imaginer que là il y a
une puissance à fournir derrière si tout
était branché en même temps qui serait
considérable j'ai pas fait le calcul je
sais pas le faire d'ailleurs mais donc
je pense que c'est logique que le coup
soit élevé je dis pas que c'est
que ça pose pas problème aux gens qui
l'utilisent mais ça me paraît assez
logique
par contre ce lot vision de l'autoroute
de demain je peux pas vous donner de
réponse comme ça monsieur mais je suis
prête à venir discuter avec vous avec un
groupe on a des groupes qui travaillent
sur la sécurité routière dans toutes les
udafes et nous on serait très heureux de
pouvoir travailler mais je peux pas vous
dire ça en quelques minutes
merci Monsieur Nadia
oui alors l'autoroute de demain je suis
un petit peu comme Madame
c'est quand même c'est quand même un peu
difficile aujourd'hui à imaginer
l'autoroute de demain
comme ça en l'espace de en l'espace de
deux minutes
en revanche on peut ça je crois qu'on
l'a tous dit on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui
on a un réseau qui est quand même
beaucoup très bien structuré en France
avec de nombreux services effectivement
sur les sur les différentes autoroutes
bon
donc peut-être il faut améliorer
certainement il y a toute façon il y a
toujours à améliorer maintenant
revoir totalement
l'autoroute de demain
j'ai pas j'ai pas particulièrement
d'idées nous avons pas particulièrement
d'idées aujourd'hui à 40 millions
après je voudrais moi revenir un petit
peu sur ce que vient de dire Madame
concernant les voies
des voix que qui seraient dédiées
au covoiturage au transport en commun
etc
bon alors déjà le covoiturage je pense
que c'est quelque chose de très bien
dans le
dans l'absolu mais on se rend compte que
ça ça ne fonctionne pas aussi bien que
cela
parce que c'est assez compliqué de
d'amener des gens à des endroits
différents alors si effectivement il y a
un fort réseau comme en région
parisienne un fort réseau de transport
en commun on peut toujours effectivement
covoiturer des gens pour aller accéder à
des transports en commun après
la fameuse voie dédiée
ça a été fait ça a été fait en région
parisienne sur les autoroutes qui qui
arrivent sur Paris et la conséquence de
cela il faut quand même faut quand même
se rendre à l'évidence que ça génère un
maximum de bouchons parce que quand vous
avez trois voies d'autoroute qui qui
arrivent sur le périphérique et puis
quand on vous en neutralise une
ça pose quand même un certain nombre de
problèmes
bon après je vous aviez tout à l'heure
évoquer des des différenciations de
tarifs et donc la proposition quand vous
a faite que que 40 millions fait ce
serait une différence par rapport à une
modulation par rapport à la période de
d'utilisation
facturer l'autoroute en fonction du
niveau de vie
je pense que là
c'est ça me paraît
ça ça me paraît assez compliqué à mettre
en oeuvre et puis je pense pas que ce
soit ce soit très opportun je veux dire
bon voilà après si on veut parler des
des
bornes de recharge rapide que dans
Madame parler
non seulement effectivement on dit il
faut une forte puissance ça c'est
certain mais
quand on sait que aujourd'hui cet hiver
on nous a dit qu'il fallait chauffer à
19 degrés dans les dans les appartements
parce que on allait avoir des des
ruptures de charges au niveau de au
niveau de l'alimentation électrique si
demain on a la moitié du parc automobile
en France qui est qui est électrique et
que on doit recharger toutes ces
voitures en même temps je sais pas
comment on va faire merci
monsieur
l'autoroute de demain ben écoutez moi je
pense qu'il faut
tenter de préserver la qualité du réseau
concédé actuel
avec
si possible des péages moindres moins
coûteux pour les utilisateurs notamment
les utilisateurs professionnels mais des
péages qui permettent cependant à l'état
de percevoir des recettes pour pouvoir
maintenir à niveau le réseau non concédé
et pas toujours vouloir
rechercher d'autres d'autres recettes
d'autres ressources par ailleurs
notamment en taxant les camions en ce
qui concerne les services je rappelle
quand même que non les pH et l'usage de
l'infrastructure les services et autres
choses qui étaient les services on les
payent en plus du pH et souvent plus
cher d'ailleurs je parle même pas des
dépannages autoroutiers pour les poids
lourds parce que là on comprend plus
rien je rappelle quand même que parfois
souvent pour un camion un dépannage
shorauto c'est plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros et qu'il n'y a pas de
grille tarifaire contrairement aux
véhicules légers d'accord donc attention
les services c'est autre chose je
rappelle
en ce qui concerne les pH toujours on
fait partie également du comité des
usagers et tous les ans on devient nous
présenter les prévisions d'augmentation
des sociétés d'autoroute et ensuite les
confirmations de d'augmentation des
sociétés d'autoroute entre temps à
chaque fois pendant une demi-heure on
nous explique la manière dont on s'est
calculé enfin pas dans le détail on
explique le foisonnement institut dans
tous les ans c'est les mêmes slides on
change la dette
mais lorsqu'on a une demande véritable
elle n'est pas on y répond pas
favorablement moi la dernière fois j'ai
demandé que on nous parle de 4,75%. donc
on nous refait les calculs les
catégories 3 et 4 on arrive à 5 5 0 5
pour les camions donc on est déjà 0,25
au dessus et ensuite on demande est-ce
qu'on pourrait avoir les moyens de
pondérées
parce que c'est très bien d'avoir
4,80 sur le tel réseau
4,60 sur tel autre réseau mais si on
pondèrent pas au nombre de kilomètres
parcourus sur ces réseaux
et en fonction des tronçons soumis à
péage et bien les 4,75 ne veulent
absolument rien dire il faut absolument
qu'on puisse obtenir des moyennes
pondérées alors on me dit que c'est très
difficile oui faisons-le quand même
comme ça on aura véritablement
l'augmentation réelle annuelle des
péages en ce qui concerne la transition
énergétique d'ailleurs du parc d'une
manière générale vlpl moi l'autre vrai
question c'est au-delà de l'équipement
sur les autoroutes et d'ailleurs sur le
réseau non concédé également c'est la
disponibilité la ressource parce que
est-ce que c'est toujours la même
question est-ce qu'on aura assez
d'électricité et sur autoroute a
fortiori parce que
il va quand même falloir avoir des des
bornes de recharge à très forte
puissance pour les poids lourds donc
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement bon un
poids lourd c'est un poids lourd c'est
pas un VL et en plus on va pas perdre de
temps non plus en temps de recharge
rappelle que c'est une activité
économique le transport contient de
marchandises
et puis en ce qui concerne la
différenciation moi je rappelle quand
même que la directive review robinet qui
va se mettre en place à partir du 1er
mars 2024 va permettre la
différenciation des péages en fonction
des émissions des véhicules et j'ai vu
hier que au niveau européen on va même
essayer d'intégrer les remorques et les
camions en fonction de leur profil
aérodynamique donc effectivement une
différenciation peut et va exister en
fonction des émissions des véhicules
voilà
merci
je vais
merci président et puis merci à nos
intervenants je vous ferai parvenir la
proposition de résolution que j'ai
rédigé déposé au Sénat et qui vise
améliorer le réseau routier en général
comme vous l'avez constaté le réseau
concédé et en très bon état ce qui n'est
pas le cas du réseau national non
concédé et ma proposition vise à mettre
l'ensemble du réseau routier à la fin
des contrats dans un établissement
public qui pourrait gérer de la même
manière le concéder et le non concédé et
améliorer l'état du non concédé des
questions pour Monsieur Landes s'il vous
plaît vous avez évoqué vous venez
d'évoquer à l'instant la directive euro
redevance qui va s'imposer à la France
c'est
on l'appelait auparavant Eurovignette et
donc je vous repose la question de de
comment vous voyez la mise en place de
cette directive en France plus
précisément parce qu'elle va intervenir
avant la fin des péages et vous avez
bien noté que le pH est l'usage d'une
infra et non d'un service et qu'à la fin
des contrats autoroutiers actuels il n'y
a plus de péage possible il faudra un
nouveau dispositif législatif j'ai bien
entendu que vous souhaitiez qu'on
maintienne des péages peu moins coûteux
pour maintenir en état le réseau pas
comme cela a été fait en Espagne avec
une gratuité démagogique sur lesquels il
s'empresse de de revenir ça c'est ma
première question sur comment vous voyez
la mise en place de robinets la deuxième
comment réagissez-vous à la concurrence
de camions étrangers qui font le plein
aux portes de notre pays le plein de
carburant et qui traverse ensuite sans
acquitter la TICPE je suis riverain de
l'A31 près du Luxembourg et c'est
absolument désastreux donc comment
voyez-vous cette question là et je la
relis à la question précédente sur la
mise en place de eurovignettes et
dernière question
comment réagissez-vous la mise en place
d'une
redevance sur la collectivité européenne
d'Alsace c'est la première ecotaxe
française qui en cours de négociation
actuellement et je sais qu'il y a des
réactions des syndicats de transporteurs
à la mise en place de cette nouvelle
écotaxe je vous remercie merci
concerne la mise en oeuvre de je vais
toujours l'appeler le directive
européenne
oui oui bon elle sera elle va être prise
en place en fonction effectivement des
émissions notamment des véhicules je
vais pas me tourner parce qu'après je
parle plus dans le micro mais
faut quand même faut quand même on
travaille on vient travailler où il y a
de finaliser la feuille de route des
carbonation des véhicules lourds qui va
être remises au ministre Beaune le 24
mai prochain et qui serait intégré la
stratégie nationale bas carbone donc on
travaille beaucoup à la décarbonation
des véhicules lourds à la transition
énergétique de notre secteur mais il
faut quand même se souvenir qu'au 1er
janvier 2022
on avait 600 616 617.000 véhicules
lourds
98,4% de ces véhicules rouleau diesel
d'accord
et 8700 au gaz naturel et les autres
types de motorisation dont l'électricité
c'est très très marginal très très
marginal
donc aujourd'hui la différenciation des
péages en fonction des émissions
ce fera que la flotte actuelle et je
rappelle que la flota actuelle pour le
transport de marchandises pour compte
d'autrui
c'est essentiellement pour les aider à
assurer par une flotte sur les longues
distances 80-85% par des euros 6
donc quand on regarde
les pièces d'émission entre euro 1 et
Euro 6 95% de l'émission en moins on
s'aperçoit que effectivement
la transition énergétique c'est déjà
faite mais avec des carburants fossiles
donc on travaille à la décarbonation et
nous nous sommes pour le mix énergétique
il n'y a pas de vraies solutions
donc Miss énergétique c'est
effectivement des carburantes synthèse
c'est toujours du diesel avec encore des
améliorations possibles sur les
motorisations c'est le gaz naturel c'est
effectivement l'électrique dans
certaines situations pas pour l'instant
sous autoroute plutôt effectivement en
logistique urbaine où là et avec des
tonnages moindres c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui de toute façon on n'a pas
d'offre au dessus de 26 tonnes et puis
ensuite
les capacités d'emports sont à limiter
en raison de la taille des batteries
donc il faut il faut avoir ça en tête
lorsqu'on va parler de modulation des
péages en fonction effectivement des
émissions sur
[Musique]
la taxe
alsacienne
on s'est battu sur cet article de la loi
climat et résilience qui permettait
alors la taxe alsacienne était
antérieure qui permettait effectivement
le recours à l'écotaxe parce que comme
je le rappelais tout à l'heure on se
prive à un moment donné en privatisant
les sociétés
autoroutières d'une de recette pour
l'État et depuis on cherche absolument à
retrouver de nouvelles recettes pour le
réseau
non concédé donc bon l'imagination est
au pouvoir
on a tout eu alors bien sûr on cherche
aussi en plus de taxer on cherche à
raboter la fameuse ristourne sur le
gazole le professionnel si on veut
regarder les chiffres c'est c'est des
sommes assez ridicule au regard des
enjeux je rappelle que la transition
énergétique du transport routier
de marchandises
est évalué à 54 milliards d'euros
et quand on parle de ristourne TICPE on
parle d'amis
donc si dans la trajectoire imaginez
mais non encore mise en oeuvre de la loi
climat est résilience de faire
disparaître la ristourne à l'horizon
travailler correctement sur la
transition énergétique et c'est pour ça
que il y a aussi une inquiétude
sur les infrastructures
avec le terme des concessions actuelles
il y a des investissements énormes à
faire et on parlait justement des
bornes de recharge de fortes puissances
sur le réseau le réseau autoroutier et
si effectivement il y a une perspective
de de fin de concession un horizon
proche les investissements se feront pas
moi j'ai lu les précédentes auditions a
bien dit que de toute façon les
investissements sont tellement lourds
qui ne se feront pas dans l'immédiat
donc ils se feront quand par qui voilà
ça c'est les vraies questions parce que
si jamais d'un côté
on nous
on nous oblige parce que c'est le cas on
est presque des
délinquants puisqu'on parle maintenant
d'itinéraires de fuite on fuit on fuit
l'autoroute mais on fuit l'autoroute
cette comme je disais tout à l'heure bon
à un moment donné il y a des
considérations économiques et également
mais les transporteurs sont des gens
intelligents puisque entre 2021 et 2022
[Musique]
comment la fréquentation autoroutière
pour les le transport routier de
marchandises étaient en augmentation de
2,5%. d'accord mais c'est sûr que pour
pour revenir à l'Alsace on voit fleurir
des interdictions de circulation pour
réorienter le trafic sur le réseau taxé
alors
bien évidemment les transporteurs
routiers alsaciens alsacien je parle pas
du transit qu'est-ce que le transit
qu'est-ce que transport routier de
marchandises de transit moi je
président Lojo est issu de la même
région que moi quand j'entends parler de
transit pour traverser Besançon et pour
éviter effectivement le contournement
par la 39 je rigole un peu parce que si
passé s'y passer effectivement de la
haine 83 l'arrivée l'arrivée par beurre
à Besançon pour traverser pour les pour
aller au nord et et
desservir et des servir une comment une
zone industrielle ou artisanale ou des
supermarchés pour éviter effectivement
à peu près 60 km d'autoroute
supplémentaire et donc les les péages
autoroutiers qui vont qui vont avec
c'est c'est de la fuite bon moi je sais
pas donc effectivement on doit se poser
beaucoup de questions on nous
conditionne pour aller sur l'autoroute
ou sur les réseaux non conseils c'est
assez surprenant
merci j'ai pas répondu sur la
concurrence étrangère effectivement
c'est très important la concurrence
étrangère se fait bien entendu pas sur
le péage autoroutier puisqu'il paie le
même péage autoroutier la concurrence
étrangère se fait très peu sur la taxe à
l'essieu parce que la taxe a les yeux
même si effectivement il y a des minimas
européens bon la France d'ailleurs est
au minima et c'est tellement dilué dans
le coup au kilomètre qu'il y a très peu
d'incidences la vraie incidence
effectivement c'est la TICPE
et le vrai avantage que peut avoir un
transporteur étranger c'est
effectivement de pouvoir faire le plein
à l'entrée du territoire national de
faire de faire même si le traverse
d'ailleurs
du nord au sud du silo du sud au nord et
donc d'échapper finalement à la taxe
française ça c'est la vraie c'est la
vraie la vraie différence et d'ailleurs
j'ai quelques j'ai quelques chiffres
le CNR a fait une simulation du coût
d'usage des infrastructure en 2022 sur
la base de 30000 km annuels parcourus
par un camion beaucoup moins de truc que
la réalité et ça nous donne les
résultats suivants je le lis parce que
je l'ai sous les yeux donc le montant
des péages
7170 euros donc c'est les fameux 30 000
km multiplié par
0,239 euros c'est la part des péages
dans le coup d'usage des infrastructures
c'est 63%, tcpe 35,9% est axe à l'essieu
1,2 pour pour cent donc si les péages
sont la composante qui pèse le plus
fortement dans le coup d'usage des
infrastructures en revanche si on
rapporte ça en termes de concurrence
étrangère c'est bien la tcpe qui fait la
différence
et c'est pas le pH et c'est pas la taxe
délicieux
merci c'est la parole à Gérard
merci monsieur le Président merci à nos
intervenants pour tous les éclairages
que vous nous apportez
mon questionnement se tournera plutôt
vers la FNTR
pardonnez-moi je viens de Bretagne et
évidemment où les routes sont gratuites
et donc évidemment parler de pH dans un
secteur Hollywood sont gratuites ça peut
paraître un peu décalé alors pas tant
que ça parce que ici tout le monde a
entendu parler
des fameux bonnets rouges pas ceux de
165 mais ceux de 2013 beaucoup
qui se sont illustrés d'ailleurs par un
certain nombre d'actions assez
spectaculaires
contre la mise en place de la fameuse
écotaxe telle qu'elle était envisagée
je dis bien telle qu'elle était
envisagée j'insiste beaucoup sur cet
aspect là
donc
en vérité la question des péages se pose
pas seulement en région mais elle se
pose par rapport à ce qu'est la mission
de la cheminement des marchandises dont
on a besoin pour vivre
or le constat que nous faisons en
Bretagne comme ailleurs
c'est que par exemple depuis la loi de
modernisation de l'économie
une entreprise qui est située tout au
bout là-bas auprès de l'océan
qui produit des denrées alimentaires
doit aujourd'hui livrer son principal
débouché
27 fois par semaine là où elle se
contentait de le livrer 9 fois par
semaine avant la Haye autrement dit la
tension émise sur le secteur de
production et sur le transporteur parce
qu'évidemment
le producteur qui fait appel aux
transporteur mais aussi un peu de
pression économique sur sur le
transporteur tentez si bien que cette
réalité là pourrait fait de pousser à la
délocalisation de la production plus
près des lieux de consommation et je le
dis pour une région comme la nôtre qui
est à la fois périphérique et
péninsulaire donc en taxant la distance
on vient aggraver cette distorsion c'est
un peu ce qui s'est passé tout le monde
ne l'a pas compris parce que je
rencontre encore parfois des collègues
qui me disent il faudrait réactiver les
kotaxes ben écoutez c'est pas la peine
de réitérer ce qui a été mis en échec je
pense qu'il faut penser les choses
autrement
et dans ce contexte là je suis amené à
vous demander quand même si la meilleure
formule ne serait pas d'obtenir des
politiques et donc de l'État
des dispositions plus favorables
en matière de financement du reportage
et singulièrement pour développer le
transport combiné parce que c'est une
vraie question moi je n'ose pas de
transfert modal au développement des
camions mais je préfère le camion
électrique qu'on met sur le train plutôt
que un camion qui est taxé de polluer
etc etc je ne développe pas il me semble
que la mesure incitative la plus
efficace serait peut-être d'obtenir une
participation beaucoup plus offensive se
remorque à ce report moderne de ce type
plutôt que de stigmatiser le camion ou
les usagers de la route
merci ces questions nous sommes les
premiers clients
des autres modes de transport de
marchandises tout simplement et nous
sommes très favorables
au report model lorsque il est possible
tout simplement nous sommes engagés
dans un programme
C2E qui s'appelle remove où nous allons
pouvoir
sensibiliser former leur sensibiliser
pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas encore l'information sur
les former pour ceux qui souhaitent
s'engager fermement sur d'autres reports
alors parce qu'on va travailler sur le
ferroviaire bien entendu sur le fluvial
on va travailler sur même sur le
cabotage maritime qui peut être très
intéressant regarde des côtes françaises
donc nous sommes très favorables
on n'a jamais pu boire dans lire dans
nos propos que nous étions opposés nous
sommes les premiers clients nous avons
des entreprises qui font une part
importante de leur activité de transport
routier de marchandises
sur d'autres modes de transport donc ce
n'est pas un souci pour nous et au
contraire nous sommes nous allons nous
engager
parce que la conventions étaient signées
les conventions remove a été signée mais
on va s'engager au cours de l'année 2023
sur trois ou quatre ans pour
effectivement travailler encore plus à
se reporter model il n'empêche que si
les objectifs étaient atteints les
objectifs gouvernementaux d'ailleurs
étaient atteint on passerait le
président disait tout à l'heure 87%, je
crois le transport routier de
marchandises nous on est à 89 enfin bon
pas 2% prêt mais si effectivement
on
atteignait les objectifs en termes de
report sur le fluvial et le ferroviaire
et on l'espère sur le ferroviaire parce
qu'avec les centaines de milliards qui
sont dépensés il va falloir s'y mettre
et bien
infini 75% des marchandises seraient
toujours transporté par un camion donc
on pourra toujours dire si vous l'avez
c'est qu'un camion vous l'a apporté à un
moment donné dans le parcours de la
marchandise
donc effectivement il faut travailler à
la fois sur le report model sur le
verdissement de la flotte et vous le
soulignez vous l'avez souligné mais
très explicitement mais il faut
également le verdissement de la flotte
ça passe également par un vrai travail
sur l'organisation du frais c'est ainsi
de suite donc et un travail aussi avec
les clients des transporteurs parce que
évidemment on peut aussi
multiplier les transports non pas de la
volonté du transporteur mais de la
simple volonté du client lui-même
merci c'est la parole Jean-Claude
merci monsieur le Président merci à tous
les intervenants alors ma question
s'adresse comme Monsieur Lens
l'État c'est délesté ou à céder on va le
dire comme ça 10000 km de route
nationale au collectivité donc région ou
département et nous avons autorisé le
je voulais vous interroger sur le
développement de nouvelles autoroutes
est-ce que vous avez un point de vue là
dessus et je vais vous interroger sur
deux points de vue parce que qui
interrogent aujourd'hui
globalement beaucoup de monde c'est là
69 Toulouse Castres et puis quelque
chose qui est cher n'est-ce pas au
Massif Central la fin de la RN de 88
donc on va dire l'axe Toulouse Lyon en
passant par Albi c'est déjà fait la 68
en passant par Rodez et en rejoignant la
75 voilà est-ce que là-dessus ou les
collectivités donc se posent se posent
en tant que maître d'ouvrage la réaction
se dit deux personnes quel est votre
point de vue sur le développement de
nouvelles autoroutes parce qu'elle a
parlé des autoroutes concédés ou non
concédés mais on travaille là-dessus et
moi j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
notamment par rapport au débat qu'on a
sur la 69 qu'on entend parce que pour
nous il est voilà mais votre point de
vue là dessus et cela la future donc la
terre le génome manquant entre Albi et
on va dire Saint-Étienne si on peut ou
Lyon en tout cas entre Rodez et Séverac
le Château pour faire simple pour
croiser le l'autoroute A75 qui vient du
Massif Central
je vais vous répondre d'une manière
générale mais je pense que c'était
sous-entendu dans mes précédents propose
tout ce qui peut améliorer la qualité
des infrastructures de transport routier
de marchandises
d'autre part tout ce qui peut permettre
au transporteur routier
de travailler en sécurité plus en
sécurité et plus rapidement
et bien sont ces bienvenus c'est
bienvenue et donc effectivement c'est
aussi la question
de la manière dont on développe manière
qualitative
le réseau routier
concédé en l'occurrence plutôt non
concédé avec les recettes adéquates qui
doit être au centre des débats
aujourd'hui
bien mais s'il n'y a plus d'autres
questions moi je remercie nos trois
intervenants pour effectivement
les précisions qui nous ont été
apportées sur le sujet
des autoroutes sur le devenir des
concessions sur sur les tarifs
bien vu effectivement que
il fallait peut-être garder du côté des
tarifs que les autoroutes étaient de
bonne qualité
effectivement et puis
nous continuerons donc nos démarches
pour se faire une opinion
[Musique]
effectivement il devrait peut-être été
bien mais peut-être que vous nous le
direz plus tard
quel est votre point de vue sur le
devenir
parce que ce serait bien qu'on puisse
l'entendre même nos officiellement parce
que c'est vrai quand on n'a pas personne
ne nous dit
on penserait que ce serait mieux comme
ça que plutôt comme ça et puis comme on
fait quelque chose sans avoir
effectivement de répondre de la part de
nos intervenants derrière c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour dire je
n'aurais pas fait ça
c'est beaucoup plus simple c'est un peu
le système français d'ailleurs
de dire vous l'avez fait mais moi si
j'avais eu des idées j'aurais pas fait
ça mais je pense que de temps en temps
un peu d'échange et un peu de conseils
nous permettrait aussi d'améliorer et
d'enrichir nos réflexions merci à vous
pour votre présence et vos réponses à
nos questions merci